الاستديوهات بعدها موجوده بس هيدا الجو مش
موجود هذا عم بحكي انا يعني هذه الصور من
الخمسينيات والستينيات القرن الماضي
الاذاعه تكاد تكون
مش رح اقول بيت الثاني بيتي هي بيتي دخلت
الى عمري 21 سنه وصار لي وحده واربعين سنه
بشتغل فيها
شاهدت ما شاهدت وشاهدت على امور عظيمه ما
كنت بتخيل بيوم من الايام اللي اشهد عليها
[موسيقى]
من الناس اللي كمان شفتهم وما تخيلت اني
اشوفهم السيده فيروز لما كانت تتدرب
باستديوهاتنا
النسخه الاصليه ما زالت موجوده محافظ
عليها موضوعها في خزائن موضوعه مرتبه
بطريقه
صحيحه ضمن ارقام ايضا هناك جهاز متخصص
للحمايه من الحريق ايضا لدينا
ما يسحب الرطوبه من من مكتبه التسجيلات
لكي نبقى نحافظ على هذه الاشرطه ان كانت
ريل او سيليا
[موسيقى]
يوم ازاله لبنان
تحافظ على الماضي طبعا بكل ما اوتيت من
خلال من خلال البرامج اللي بعدها لليوم عم
تعملها وتنتجها مستعينه بارشيف اذاعه
لبنان لحتى ما من الصنادينا مش لحتى نضل
نرجع بعيد مش لحتى نضل بالماضي لحتى
نستوحي من جمال بعض ورقي الماضي وانعصت
[موسيقى]
اذاعه لبنان من بيروت الى كل لبنان